The agreeableness trait that
divides men and women most.
There's three things that divide women
and men most particularly from the
psychometric perspective.
One is that women are
more agreeable than men.
And so that seems to be the primary
maternal dimension as far as I can tell.
It's associated with,
um,
a desire to avoid conflict.
But it's,
it's associated with
interpersonal closeness,
compassion,
politeness.
Women are reliably higher than men,
especially in the Scandinavian
countries and in the countries where
egalitarianism has
progressed the farthest.
So that's where the differences maximize,
which is one of the things James Demora
pointed out quite correctly in his
infamous Google memo.
Okay.
Women are higher in negative emotion.
So that's anxiety and emotional pain,
that that difference is
approximately the same size.
And again,
that maximizes any Galitary in societies,
which is extremely interesting.
And then the biggest difference is the
difference in interest between people and
things.
And so women are more interested in
people and men are more interested in
things,
which goes along quite nicely
with your car anecdote.
But the thing about men interacting with
men again is that it isn't that they
respect each other's viewpoints.
That's not exactly right.
What happens with a man,
and I know a lot of men that I would
regard is as remarkably tough people for
one reason or another.
And everything you do with
them is a form of combat.
Like if you want your
viewpoint taken seriously,
often you have to yell them down and
like they're not going to stop talking
unless you start talking over them.
You know,
and it's,
it's not like are automatically giving
respect to other men because that just
doesn't happen.
Instead,
the combat is there and it's
expected and one of the problems,
and so this is part of the reason
why I think men are bailing out of,
of so much of academia and,
and,
and maybe the academic world in general,
and maybe the world in general,
is that men actually don't have
any idea how to compete with women.
Because the problem is,
is that if you unleash
yourself completely,
then you're an absolute bully.
And there's no doubt about that because
if men unleash themselves on other men,
that can be pretty God damn brutal,
especially for the men that
are really tough and this,
so that just doesn't happen with women.
But so you can't unleash
yourself completely if you,
when you're a bully,
if you lose while you're
just bloody pathetic.
So how the hell are you supposed
to play a game like that?
You know?
So in,
I've worked with lots of women in
law firms and in Canada for example,
and,
and high achieving women,
like really remarkable people,
I would say.
And they're often nonplussed,
I would say by the attitude of the man
in the law firm because they would like
to see everyone pulling together because
they're all part of the same team,
whereas the manner like at
each other's throats in an,
in a cooperative way because they
want the law firm to succeed,
but they want to be the person who's
at the top of the success hierarchy.
Right.
So,
and that,
that doesn't jive well with
the more competitive or
cooperative ethos that's and
parcel of agreeableness.
And so we don't really have any idea how
to integrate male and female dominant
tower Gleason.
Thanks.
Exactly.
That's exactly right.
This is why I love this show.
And we real housewives.
And I went to,
which is the fourth item scorings
and just said just last night,
okay.
I was watching one episode all right.
Where the women were at each other.
Okay.
At a party and in,
in recounting.
But I said this to you and,
but you said this to me.
And he was like,
and the men I got,
we got together there and said,
well,
this is the way they
communicate with each other.
And antisense ended up,
you know,
men,
we men,
okay,
just,
we'll have a fist fight and wheel him in.
10 minutes later we're going to have a
beer at the bar where they sat next to
each other and so on.
And I have observed that mine to mine,
my daughter,
my daughter used to be really
irritated about that because she,
she,
like most people,
uh,
was the target of feminine.
Uh,
conspiratorial bullying at
one is she's no pushover,
my daughter.
So this wasn't like this was a continual
thing or that she didn't know what to
do about it,
but she had to observe these
girls conspiring against
her and then blackening or
name on,
on Facebook,
which is part of it,
part and parcel of the typical
female bullying routine,
which is often reputation demolition,
right.
That there's a good literature on that.
And then she'd watched what would happen
if my brother or my son would have a
dispute with his friends,
you know,
and maybe they were drinking and there
was a dispute they'd have a fight and
then the next day they were friends again.
And that's another thing that's strange
is that like men have a way of bringing
a conflict to a head
and resolving it right.
And that it isn't obvious to
me that women have that same,
perhaps you might call it a luxury,
but it's also the case that men don't
know what to do when they get into a
conflict with a woman because what
the hell are you supposed to do?
You know,
mostly what you're
supposed to do is avoid it.
Well,
I think,
um,
you know,
I don't know whether this
crosses into other countries,
but that there was a certain kind of
taunting and teasing that men and boys do
with each other that toughens them.
Okay.
And,
and where they don't,
they don't take things seriously,
but a girl's feelings become extremely
hurt to have to hear something like that.
It was very tough,
you know,
again,
like sarcastic against her.
So I,
I do feel that there are
profound differences between
the sexes in terms of your
emotions,
in terms of communication patterns.
I know my father used to say that
he could never follow women's can
conversations.
He said,
here's the deal.
women don't even finish
the finish sentences there.
Then with the women understand immediately
what the other woman is saying.
Okay.
Uh,
and um,
the,
in the way the women tend to be more
interested in or have been traditionally
more interested in soap operas,
it's not just the women who were
home without jobs is that I honestly,
I believe that soap opera does reflect,
does mirror the way
women talk to each other.
Those are,
these communication patterns have been
built up through women in the world of
women.
Okay.
Which,
which was it made sense?
There was a division of labor.
Okay.
It wasn't sexism against women
that there was a division of labor.
The men went off to hunt and
did the dangerous things.
The women stayed around the hearth
because you had pregnant women,
nursing women,
older women were cooking and so on.
So I feel that these
communication patterns that
we're talking about have been
built up over the centuries and
the men had to toughen each other.
Okay.
It took a while to go out and you know,
the hunting parties and native Americans,
you know,
it would be,
they could be gone for two weeks and when,
when the temperature was below
zero and in many of them die.
Yeah.
The idea that somehow,
oh,
any kind of separation of the sexes
or different spheres of the sexes is
inherently sexist.
And
the answer to all of this,
okay.
That everything that we're talking about,
Is Education into early history.
Okay.
And until you are,
until people understand the stone age,
but nomadic period,
the agrarian era and how culture,
how civilization built up.
Okay.
In Mesopotamia,
the great irrigation projects,
or in or in Egypt where you had,
for the first centralized government
authority became necessary.
Okay.
To master these,
these,
um,
you know,
we had a situation where
at an environmentally,
uh,
you know,
difficult situation like the
deserts of Mesopotamia or,
or the,
the peculiar character of,
of Egyptian geography where you
can only have a little tiny,
tiny,
fertile line along the edges of the Nile.
Okay.
And not otherwise it desert landscape.
So th this civilization and a 14.
Okay.
All right.
I ask not necessarily
about power grabbing,
but about organization to achieve
something for the good of the people as a
whole.